plus de six millions et demi
d'ukrainiens ont quitté leur pays depuis
le début de cette offensive russe fin
février selon le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés de l'onu et plus de trois
millions d'entre eux ont trouvé refuge
en pologne voisine à varsovie justement
en pologne on va tout de suite retrouvé
caroline de camaret notre envoyé spécial
caroline avec quel est l'état d'esprit
des polonais face à cette guerre qui se
déroule à leur porte
alors déjà le président polonais
président duda est revenu ici à varsovie
après une visite hier même à kiev une
visite dont j'ai discuté avec le
ministre des affaires étrangères qui est
la troisième du genre et donc les
polonais se considèrent comme les
champions de l'aide à l'ukraine et en
particulier qui permettent de donner des
leçons ce petit pays de 40 millions
d'habitants qui est dirigé par des
ultraconservateurs à leurs voisins comme
la hongrie dont on estime que viktor
orban est assez ambigu vis-à-vis de
poutine mais également les allemands
qu'ils estiment beaucoup trop ambigu
aussi sur les embargos sur le gaz et
puis même les français qui ne selon eux
ne voudrais pas suffisamment une
adhésion de la l'ukraine à l'union
européenne
alors c'est vrai que jusqu'à présent et
bien les polonais étaient plutôt mal vu
par l'union européenne parce que il
avait tenté de mettre la main avec ce
parti ultraconservateur dont droit et
justice sur leur système judiciaire et
donc ni en l'état de droit ils avaient
ils encourraient des sanctions est
effectivement leur plan de relance à 24
milliards d'euros est gelé mais en
attendant on sent bien que à bruxelles
le ton a changé depuis la guerre en
ukraine on estime que ils font des
efforts considérables en particulier
vous l'avais dit dans l'accueil des
réfugiés ukrainien et plus de 3 millions
d'ukrainiens sont arrivés en pologne
caroline est ce que leur accueil
aujourd'hui pose des problèmes
logistiques au pays
tout à fait alors c'est à dire que on
estime comme moi la moitié vont rester
en fait vont rester plus longtemps que
ça n'est pas un accueil complètement
provisoire alors c'est vrai que du coup
il y à une augmentation de 20% des prix
des loyers il y a eu une loi qui a été
votée au niveau national une loi
d'urgence qui leur permettaient pendant
18 mois d'obtenir un accueil la sécurité
sociale la possibilité de rechercher un
emploi cela est bienvenu dans certains
secteurs comme la restauration il
manquer de main d'oeuvre et toutes ces
femmes ukrainiennes et leurs enfants et
bien vont pouvoir supplée en revanche
c'est vrai que du côté du bâtiment il ya
80 milles ukrainien qui habitait ici en
pologne qui sont retournés faire la
guerre en ukraine est donc là il ya des
déficits mais en attendant et bien ils
ont eu un accueil beaucoup plus
important et vraiment bien réels par
rapport à 2015 les syriens à les
polonais ne voulait prendre aucun aucun
réfugié là en l'occurrence il espère
mettre dans la balance cet accueil des
ong surtout de la société civile est un
tout petit peu moins du gouvernement
mais en tout cas il ya une sorte d'union
sacrée quand même sur cette question des
réfugiés il espère le mettre en avant
toujours ce gouvernement je le disais
pour soutirer à l'union européenne
encore plus des quelques milliards
supplémentaires pour aider véritablement
dans le pays à cet accueil merci
beaucoup caroline de camaret en direct
de varsovie en